знімай знімай прибрати ТЦК з вулиць
вдосконалити мобілізацію і цифровізувати
армію цього за словами слуг народу
іміноборони дозволить досягти
електронний реєстр
військовозобов'язаних Верховна Рада
ухвалила відповідний закон згідно з ним
Міноборони отримає дані про громадян
віком від 17 до 60 років що містяться у
різних державних реєстрах податкової
Мінюсту Міністерства охорони здоров'я
ЦВК державної мігра
служби та інших відомств перша і головна
мета полягає в тому щоб у Генерального
штабу в Міністерства оборони були
розуміння щодо мобілізаційних ресурсів в
державі відповідно до яких будуть
створюватись мобілізаційні резерви для
здійснення ротацій тих хто перебуває в
зоні бойових дій від початку
широкомасштабного вторхнення роботу
електронного реєструпід назвою оберіг
запустили в Україні з минулого року але
не на повну доступ до нього мають ТЦК
тепер в оберіг надійде ще більше даних з
державних реєстрів реєстр
військовозобов'язаних призовників
резервістів е наповнюється даними власне
військовозобов'язаних має ключові обміни
з великими державними реєстрами в режимі
realtime наповнений на 88 процесі
процетів
верифікація майже завершилася як
інструмент для роботи з
війзьковозобов'язаними для направлення
повісток для того щоб вести облік і так
далі реєстр є повністю робочим
інструментом законопроєкт про реєстр
військовозобов'язаних ще має підписати
президент України коли реєстр остаточно
запрацює усі військовозобов'язані
резервісти і призовники матимуть свій
електронний кабінет тудип підтягнуться
їхні персональні дані зокрема сімейний
стан місце роботи картка платника
податків а також номери телефонів адреси
електронної пошти дані про володіння
іноземними мовами документи на зброю
водійське посвідчення і навіть
відцифрований образ обличчя у Міноборони
наголошують усі ці дані потрібні для
того щоб налагодити процес мобілізації
зокрема реєстр запустить розумний
рекрутинг до війська реєстр буде мати
утлітарну функцію щодо формування
шортлістів на підставі яких рекрутин
рекрутери рекрутингові е Скажімо так
інституції Міністерства оборони які
будуть мати доступ зможуть
маршрутизувати людей більш фахово для
того щоб ми могли визначити і
запропонувати
військовозобов'язаному таке
Скажімо так місце в Збройних Силах або в
силах оборони яке на найбільш крутим
чином розкриє його е Скажімо так Так
його навички завдяки електронному
реєстру документи які ТЦК зберігали у
папках перейдуть у цифровий формат
Наприклад якщо військовозобов'язаний
одружиться інформація про це автоматично
надійде в реєстр також ТЦК зможе
автоматично за запитом перевірити чи
дійсно військовозобов'язаний навчається
в університеті на денній формі і має
право на відстрочку довідку з місця
навчання не потрібно буде приносити
особисто у Міноборони запевняють циф
взація допоможе боротися з корупцією в
ТЦК зменшить черги бюрократичну тяганину
і випадки повторного вручення повісток
ми зможемо зменшити
кількість помилково надісланих повісток
тобто люди будуть отримувати
повістки ну якби вже абсолютно цільовим
чином і не буде жодних помилок ми
зможемо направити саме тому
військовозобов'язаному який є нашою
цільовою аудиторією Утім отримува згоду
на зберігання й обробку цих даних від
самих військовозобов'язаних закон не
вимагає Щодо цієї норми висловило
застереження Головне науково-експертне
управління апарату Верховної Ради адже
вона може порушити норми Конституції про
права громадян і захист конфіденційних
даних з моєї точки зору це пряме
порушення чинного закону Про захист
персональних даних і я не виключаю що це
може
спричинити судові позови проти в даному
випадку держателя реєстру Міністерства
оборони через
достатньо неякісно виписано цю
нормативну пропозицію цю норму в
законопроекті виконавчий директор
Української Гельсінської Спілки
Олександр Павліченко також Застерігає
єдиний реєстр буде досить вразливою
базою даних якщо її вдасться зламати до
рук зловмисників може потрапити особиста
зокрема фінансова інформація десятків
тисяч людей тут є питання взагалі
скажімо доречності ось створення
такої надмірної за
обсягом бази даних і тут так само
виникає питання належного захисту цієї
бази даних щоб у нас не були такі
випадки як наприклад із ламом того ж
самого серверу Київстару водночас хоча
дані віковозобов'язаних зберігатимуться
в електронному форматі про електронні
повістки поки не
[музика]
йдеться